when director baz luhrman took on the
artistic challenge of modernizing
Shakespeare's Romeo and Juliet for the
grunge listening Youth of the 90s he
understood the importance of selecting
the right actors for the leading roles
hot off his Oscar nomination for What's
Eating Gilbert Grape the young and
Charming Leonardo DiCaprio was an
obvious choice for the Lovestruck Romeo
his Juliet on the other hand was a more
difficult find although we now know the
role eventually went to my so-called
LifeStar Claire Danes she wasn't the
first or even second choice for the part
originally Lerman had cast Then 14 year
old Natalie Portman the age was fitting
for the original character but when a 21
year old DiCaprio came into the picture
the problematic age Gap quickly became
apparent Portman told the New York Times
in 1996 fox said it looked like Leonardo
DiCaprio was molesting me when we kissed
lurman agreed saying in a 2022 interview
with the New York Times she was 14 and
when you see Leo in the flesh he's a
tall young man and you just realized she
was too young Natalie was amazing in the
footage but it was too much of a burden
for her at that age